- Hi everyone. My name is
Ricardo Alvarez-Pimentel,
and I am graduating this year
with my doctorate in History.
I'm very excited to be one
of this year's recipients
of the Theron Rockwell Field Prize.
And I wanna go ahead
and begin by congratulating
my fellow winners
and what I'm sure is fantastic work.
I'd also like to take a moment
to thank my doctoral advisor,
Gilbert Joseph in the history department,
as well as other members of my committee,
for supporting this research
before, during, and after
the COVID-19 pandemic.
Lastly, I wanna begin by
also thanking my family,
who's with me here today,
for supporting me ever since
I sat foot on Yale campus
the first year of my graduate
school program in 2014.
Couldn't have done it without any of you.
So thank you.
The title of my dissertation is,
"From Secret War to Cold
War: Race, Catholicism,
and the Un-making of
Counterrevolutionary Mexico,
1917 to 1946."
Essentially, my dissertation explores
a counterrevolution religious movement
that tried to undo the consequences
of Mexico's seemingly
progressive 1910 Revolution.
Some of the legacies of
this revolution included:
separation between church and state
manifested in anti-clerical policies,
the mandating of secular
and socialist education
for all Mexican youth,
the nationalization of the economy,
and greater rights for women
and indigenous workers,
etcetera.
I study the movements that
opposed all of those measures,
as spearheaded by upper
class, middle and upper class,
Catholic women and youth groups.
Now, my dissertation traces
a very interesting evolution
of political ideologies.
Beginning in 1917,
I began to talk about this
movement as one that has espoused
and adopted predominantly
democratic and liberal ideals
in its fight against
anti-clerical authoritarianism.
However, by the 1930s,
we begin to see that the same movement
began to adopt authoritarian
political models
and even flirt with fascism,
for reasons which I will
explain in just a second.
Finally, by the early 1940s,
we begin to see a convergence
of church and state interest,
and the effective end
of the counterrevolution
as it integrated itself
to the Mexican postrevolutionary state.
My dissertation essentially argues
that the reason for these
transformations was race.
And the reason why this
movement essentially failed
was racism.
My dissertation demonstrate
that this was a movement
that was driven and undone
primarily by perceptions
and notions of whiteness.
And it takes religious discourse
as presented by these organizations
and analyzes the racialized dimensions,
sometimes lying in the subtext
of what was being explicitly conveyed.
Thus, my dissertation phrases,
the evolution of racism
in Mexican society,
just as it traces
the evolution of this
counterrevolutionary movement,
from a secret war that was
fought between church and state
not just in Mexico, but
also across the Atlantic,
particularly in countries
like Spain and the US,
to a Cold War that brought
church and state together
and their joint interest
to suppress working class
indigenous mobilization.
I look forward to talking
more about this work
throughout today,
tomorrow, and even after.
Feel free to follow me
on Twitter actually,
at RAlvarez-Pi.
I'd like to take a moment
to thank the committee again
for rewarding my work
with this recognition.
And I'd also like to take a moment
to congratulate the members
of the class of 2022.
Congratulations.
- Hello, I'm Anna Duensing,
graduating with a PhD
from the department of History
and African-American studies.
I'm a historian of the United
States in the modern world,
specializing in African-American history
black internationalism,
in the evolving politics
of white supremacy
in the United States
across the 20th century.
And I'm a 2022 winner of the Porter Prize
for my dissertation,
"Fascists without Labels:
Jim Crow, Civil Rights,
and the Making of a Black
Antifascist Tradition,
1933 to 1977."
"Fascist Without Labels"
chronicles a diffuse network
of black radical thinkers,
activists, and their grassroots
multiracial coalitions,
as they organized to sound alarm
over homegrown fascism
in the United States,
initially during the age of Jim Crow.
In addition to identifying and
combating white supremacists
who actively worked to
merge fascist ideologies,
practices, and aesthetics
with distinctly American
political traditions,
these figures confronted
what they identified
as undeniable parallels,
echoes, and overlaps
between global fascism and
the normal daily-functioning
of politics in the United States.
My work illuminates the richness
of the black antifascist
tradition of the 1930s and 1940s.
Yet my research is ultimately focused
on tracking the way
these figures mobilized
in the post-war period
against fascist afterlife
possessing segregationist,
and their supporters,
and those many lawmakers, state officials,
and everyday white people
who remained deeply committed
to a politics of white supremacy
and to anti-black violence,
even after Jim crow's ostensible demise
with the civil rights
triumphs of the 1960s.
My dissertation offers a
history of black radicalism
and modern conservatism in
conversation and in contestation.
It tells a story of white
supremacy, racial nationalism,
vigilantism, and state
violence in the United States,
while elevating a globally-minded
black freedom struggle
in which black radical
thinkers, activists,
civil rights leaders, and everyday people
vigilantly analyzed and underscored
the practices and processes
that kept fascism alive in this country.
Anti-fascism, I argue,
was essential element
of black activist struggles
for justice and liberation
across the 20th century.
And it is essential history
for understanding and
navigating our present moment.
Thanks very much for this award
and congratulations to
everyone graduating this year.
- Hi, I'm Jill Tan, a
third year PhD candidate
in anthropology.
I study death and dying in Singapore,
and work with a funeral profession.
As a writer, artist, and researcher,
I'm committed to collaborative practice
and multimodal exploration
through games, performance, and poetics.
I'm a 2022 winner of the Field Prize.
My prize submission is entitled,
"Notes on the bicentennial
of a f/l/ound/er/ing (2019)"
This multimedia work of hybrid poetry
which is video, sculpture,
and performance elements,
grew out of my poem
essay of the same title
on British imperialism in Singapore.
Through this work,
I explore how my
subjectivity as a Singaporean
has resulted in an entrench to reap
misrecognition of colonial violence
as a birthmark rather than a scab.
As a Singaporean who has
been taught not to notice
how the enduring violence
of imperial corporate power
structures my way in the world,
I began making this work
to reflect upon 2019
as the bicentennial of the
British colonization of Singapore
in 1819.
This work takes several forms;
its origin as poetic text,
voiced as part of a soundscape,
and as a visually and materially
mediated archival object
where in paper pulp is molded
into sculpture, on film,
and in performance.
In my work,
I explore how as a method
and expression of inquiry,
the poetic holds within
itself a built-in resistance
to foreclosure.
I find that the poetic
is a bespoke contraption
for mapping out gestures,
which also embody the
qualities of research design
that I seek in my ethnographic practice
as an anthropologist.
The poetic moves, and is moved
by the ethnographic object in motion.
Following its charge
can be a way of writing
and doing ethnography
that instantiates and creates.
It sits to flow and force.
In making this work, the
poetic lent the dual modalities
of accretion and attrition,
and a visual rather than textual literacy,
using not only reductions and illusions,
but cleavage and sequence to build my case
of a lost consciousness.
As I moved through building
by way of unlearning,
I thought of this hybrid poem
not only as a simulacrum,
of archival form and formulation,
but as an entry in itself.
I not only suggest the text
status as archival object
through formal mimesis
of a historical document,
but forge an archival encounter within it,
by excerpting and then deconstructing
my own writings from 2009
on Singapore's national
historical narratives.
Poetics can serve as a pushback
against the predisposition
towards classification of
the post-colonial archive,
that narratives almost always feed into
without deserting the literary entirely.
Without as much stock placed
in arch and teleology,
the poetic, as a contraption
for a contingent moving object,
destabilizes the archive upon entry.
Thank you.
(logo whooshing)